the thesis that Bernie is advancing here
it's okay to be angry about capitalism
he's got a little bit of a point
I don't know when conservatives became
the capitalists we became the promoters
of capitalism or really almost any ISM
whatsoever I'm skeptical of pretty much
all isms and let's not forget capitalism
is a word that was popularized by Karl
Marx okay what does it mean what is
capitalism
there are plenty of problems with
if by capitalism we mean
the modern system of Industry the way
that the economy were there are problems
with the way the economy works now
Bernie thinks there's problems with the
way the economy works because he wants
to steal all the money from anybody
who's richer than him and he wants to
flatten out society and he wants the
workers of the world to unite in a
proletarian Communist Revolution all
right that's all wrong
but I've got problems with the way the
economy works I think the way the
economy works right now is rigged
against against many good Americans